تسبب بقتل نحو الفي شخص ذبحا مرتكبا واحده
من اعنف المجازر حول العالم اختبا لتسعه
وعشرين عاما قبل ان تقبض عليه الشرطه
اليوم انه السفاح الروندي فولكينز الذي تم
اعتقاله في بلده صغيره بجنوب افريقيا قرب
العاصمه بعد ملاحقه ارهقت الكثير من
الضباط وبالمناسبه كاشيما كان ضابط شرطه
سابقا وجهت اليه تهمه تورطه بجريمه اباده
جماعيه
استمرت لمئه يوم كاشما توطى مع قاده جماعه
الهوتو المتطرفين عبر التخطيط لذبح اكثر
من 2000 شخص من جماعه التوتسي والمشاركه
بقتلهم بعدما لجاوا الى احدى الكنائس في
بلده تابعه لمحافظه كيبر الروانديه خلال
الحرب الاهليه التي نشبت بين الجماعتين
عام
1994 التي قتل فيها ما يقرب من الثمانيات
الف شخص كحصيله اجماليه